bonjour bonjour vous êtes coordinateur
de la france insoumise député de la
première circonscription du nord est
candidat à votre réélection aux
élections législatives nous sommes
ensemble pendant une vingtaine de
minutes pour un entretien en partenariat
avec la presse régionale qui est
représenté aujourd'hui par le journal
ouest france avec stéphane bern et
directeur de la rédaction parisienne de
ouest france bonjour stéphane bonjour
bonjour bonjour à des quatre nations va
commencer par une réaction sur la
nouvelle qui est tombée hier et ce
journaliste français qui a été tué en
ukraine frédéric leclerc imhoff 32 ans
il travaillait pour bfm tv il a été
touché par un éclat d'obus dans l'est du
pays alors qu'il suivait un convoi
humanitaire à ces la france la liberté
de la presse qui sont touchés au coeur
avec ce décès évidemment j'adresse
toutes mes condoléances aux proches à la
famille de frédéric leclef rim of à la
rédaction de vos confrères de bfm tv à
tous les journalistes c'est la guerre
dans toute sa cruauté qui touchait en
plus la profession de journaliste et je
forme le voeu que toutes les les
circonstances de la mort de frédéric
leclerc imhoff soient éclaircies et puis
surtout que les responsables de ces
crimes paix voilà parce que là on voit
très bien de quoi il s'agit désormais en
ukraine quand on bombarde des civils on
s'attaque à des journalistes quand on
bombarde des maternités comme on l'a vu
à quelques mois on est dans les crimes
de guerre et donc cela doit être
sanctionné durement le parc national
antiterroriste a ouvert une heure à
offrir une enquête pour crimes de guerre
sur ce qui s'est passé est ce que vous
pensez que ça peut vraiment permettre de
connaître toutes les circonstances est
ce que ce type de démarche est utile
c'est je crois que c'est la sixième
enquête de cette nature ouverte en
ukraine 1 je le souhaite et il faut que
ces enquêtes aille au bout et que les
responsables ps je les dix
autres questions sur le cren adrien
quatre ans puisque les 27 pays membres
de l'union européenne se sont mis
d'accord hier sur de nouvelles sanctions
contre la russie avec notamment un
embargo à 90% sur le pétrole russe ce
sont des mesures suffisantes des
sanctions fut suffisante selon
incontestablement et prendre des mesures
il faut accroître la pression sur
vladimir poutine cette guerre dure
vladimir poutine a depuis des mois fait
le choix de la guerre il a envahi le
voisin ils le respectent aucun des
éléments du droit international donc il
faut accroître les sanctions alors après
il faut regarder de plus près quel type
de sanctions et quelles conséquences
nous ne cessons de dire depuis le début
que ce qu'il faut faire c'est taper
durement au portefeuille les oligarques
autour de vladimir poutine pour en
quelque sorte l'isoler et faire en sorte
que son pouvoir ne tiennent plus que des
gens qui aujourd'hui ont intérêt à être
à ses côtés finissent par se dire mais
qu'avons nous a commenté ray à suivre ce
personnage qui fait le choix de la
guerre parce que ça ça a été fait c'est
pas pas suffisamment ça n'a pas été fait
suffisamment sûre rien qu'en france si
vous regardez dans le sud de la france
sur la côte d'azur vous faites le tour
des unions départementales syndical on
va vous montrer les endroits où se
trouvent les grandes propriétés qui
n'ont toujours pas été saisi les yachts
qui ne l'ont toujours pas été non plus
parce que la difficulté avec les
sanctions économiques tous azimuts c'est
que quand il ne faudrait pas solidifier
le peuple russe avec le dirigeant qui
choisit la guerre nous n'y avons pas
enterré de la même manière j'ai vu comme
vous que les chinois apportent en
quelque sorte leur soutien en disant
tous les secteurs économiques qui vont
être sanctionnés eh bien nous
investirons dedans at on intérêt et nous
autres à un bloc sino russes qui se
constitueraient je ne le crois pas en
revanche on ne peut pas rester c'est
clair affaires de l'incantation donc il
faut des sanctions dures l'une des
difficultés qu'on a par exemple c'est
que l'essentiel du patrimoine des
oligarques russes l'essentiel de leur
argent se trouve dans les paradis
fiscaux européens paradis fiscaux qui
d'ailleurs ont été retirés par le
concours des manuels macron de la liste
des paradis fiscaux européens voilà
autant de mesures qu'il s'agirait de
semences pour les sanctionner
véritablement à côté de ça il nous faut
des initiatives diplomatiques
par exemple une conférence
internationale comme l'a proposé jean
luc mélenchon parce que comme beaucoup
de responsables politiques d'ailleurs
lundi entre la diplomatie mais il faut
activer la diplomatie et la guerre
totale il n'y a pas d'alternative donc
faut choisir la diplomatie en revanche
on peut pas rester les bras ballants
face ars qui est en train de faire
vladimir poutine et si je vous comprends
bien se passer choisir délibérément de
se passer de l'essentiel du pétrole
russe d'ici la fin et au niveau de
l'union européenne c'est pas un bon
choix en tout cas il nous faut les
alternatives incontestablement et on
pourrait en trouver quelques unes par
exemple jean luc mélenchon a proposé ce
si vous avez de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée nos amis des pays du
maghreb qui sont eux y perd dépendant de
l'importation de blé lait d'amande du
blé ukrainien on pourrait imaginer un
moratoire sur l'epr pourrait imaginer en
discuter avec eux leur garantir nous
l'accès à un blé à des prix qui ne soit
pas spéculatif et en contrepartie leur
demander par exemple un accès au pétrole
dont il dispose à un prix qui soit
supportable par la population française
voilà quelques solutions que nous avons
en revanche il ne faut jamais être naïf
sur les rapports de force géopolitiques
qui se joue y compris derrière la
question de l'énergie parce que quand
vous avez certain qu'ils se dépêchent de
dire il faut l'embargo à tout prix sur
le pétrole et le gaz russe notamment les
américains qui nous y encourage
fortement pourquoi parce qu'ils y ont
eux mêmes des intérêts vous savez que là
bas ils ont le pétrole et le gaz de
schiste et que le prix du baril a
beaucoup augmenté donc il faut
absolument pas être naïf mais par contre
c'est clair on ne peut pas rester les
bras ballants devant ce type de
situation que nous voyons en ukraine
adrien quatre nations va évoquer la
polémique qui continue sur le fiasco de
l'organisation de la finale de la ligue
des champions samedi soir au stade de
france à saint-denis avec un ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin qui pointe
la responsabilité des dizaines de
milliers de supporters britanniques qui
sont venus au stade sans billet ou avec
des faux billets il parle d'une fraude
massive industriel qu'est ce que vous
pensez de toutes ces explications qui a
donné le ministre ilir moi je pense
d'abord la responsabilité du duo
l'allemand dharmanand dont on voit
depuis des années maintenant qu'ils sont
incapables de gérer en région parisienne
des grands événements qu'il s'agisse
d'événements sportifs comme ce qu'on a
vu au stade de france mais d'ailleurs
c'est pas que le stade de france c'est
aussi ce qu'on a vu à la fan zone à
nation ou là y avait pas d'histoire de
faux billets et tout le reste avec des
scènes absolument insupportable mais il
ya quelques temps les manifestations
revendicatives vous souvenez des gilet
jaune et tous les débordements donc le
couple l'allemande arman en est
incapable de gérer la sûreté des
événements et la tranquillité publique
voilà c'est toujours le chaos avec eux
et donc à des responsabilités politiques
pour ce qui est de monsieur l'allemand
ça fait longtemps que nous disons qu'il
n'est plus à la hauteur et que c'est
bien la chaîne de commandement la
doctrine d'utilisation des forces de
l'ordre qui est en cause et pour ce qui
est de monsieur darmanin et une élection
bientôt peut-être que les électeurs
pourraient s'en occuper aussi parce que
clairement on a bien un problème au
niveau de la chaîne de commandement
c'est d'abord ça qu'il faut dire sur les
événements qui se sont déroulés et quand
on voit que dans quelques temps on va
avoir la coupe du monde de rugby où les
jo très franchement il ya de quoi
s'inquiéter et c'est bien là
hiérarchique est en cause dans ce qui
s'est produit quand vous voyez la presse
étrangère par les deux stades de farce
et vient la france est humilié dans
cette affaire donc bien sûr qu'il ya des
responsabilités politiques il ya une
commission d' enquête qui va sourire ou
au sénat et je crois que ses
responsabilités politiques elles doivent
être doivent être prises alors vous
pointer à la responsabilité notamment de
la stratégie policière à charles
darmanin pointe les supporters
britanniques est ce que vous condamnez
aussi ces bandes de jeunes de
seine-saint-denis et d'ailleurs qui ont
participé à ces violences avec des vols
des pillages pour les condamnés en mai
toutes les toutes les violences sont à
condamner c'est pas le problème en
revanche il ya un objectif précis qu'est
donné à la police dans ce pays c'est de
garantir la tranquillité le fait que les
événements et compris les grands
événements se tiennent dans la sûreté et
du point de vue de la doctrine employés
pour le maintien de l'ordre nous avons
un grave problème voilà il ya des
endroits où y compris face à des
manifestations et y compris à des
risques de débordements on n'emploie pas
ce genre de méthode et on arrive par un
emploi d'une autre doctrine à faire en
sorte que les évènements soient
contenues par ailleurs il ya aussi un
problème dans nos services de
renseignement dire qu'il faut beaucoup
plus de moyens humains notamment dans
les services de renseignement quand vous
voyez la quantité annoncé de faux
billets qui auraient été vendus pourquoi
tout cela n'a pas été anticipé ça aussi
c'est du renseignement et on a de graves
carences aussi de ce côté là alors vous
pointez la police les services de
renseignement mais quand même on a vu
ces images de bande de n qui agressent
les supporters qui veulent c'est quand
même un supporter à sa
personne n'a agressé personne mais en
attendant vous pouvez supporter que sur
un événement comme si l'agression bien
sûr il
n'a agressé personne c'est entendu il y
en a qu'on peut peut-être faire
l'économie de se dire sur lot de
banalités en revanche ce qui se passe
c'est que visiblement nous n'étions pas
prêts à accueillir cet événement si nous
n'y étions pas préparés il fallait pas
se porter candidat au fait que
l'événement se tiennent versa un
retentissement bien au-delà de nos
frontières nous sommes là la risée du
monde là dans cet événement on vous
entend mais vous ne vous ne reconnaissez
aucune circonstance atténuante aux
pouvoirs publics en france le fait par
exemple que non parce qu'une question
devait se tenir à saint pétersbourg et
oui bien entendu tous trois mois pour la
préparer c'est quand il a lancé qu'il
fallait pas y être candidat simplement
c'est à dire que quand on n'est pas
capable d'organiser des événements et
puis surtout je le dis il y a des
précédents ce n'est pas la première fois
que monsieur darmanin et monsieur
l'allemand ratent leur mission qui est
d'assurer la sûreté la tranquillité
publique y compris je le dis quand la
des manifestations revendicatives dans
une manifestation revendicative la
police n'a pas à se vivre et à agir
comme adversaire de la manifestation est
là à garantir le fait que la
manifestation puisse se tenir et s'il ya
des éléments je vais dans votre sens
s'il ya des éléments qui viennent
perturber comme on l'a vu à l'occasion
de certains premiers mais tout le reste
mais c'est le rôle de la police de ne
pas faire de confusion et de garantir à
celles et ceux qui viennent pour
revendiquer de pouvoir le faire sans
craindre pour leur sécurité dans les
précédents on sait que dans la culture
du club de liverpool il ya aussi cette
pratique de l'utilisation de faux
billets de faux pas de fausses
accréditations il ya déjà eu des
précédents vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
les services de renseignement est ce
qu'un des problèmes de cette affaire
c'est pâques les les justement que les
services de renseignements qu
renseignements n'était pas bon mais je
dédie ce qui est ce qu'ils n'ont pas
surévalué et le nombre de il ya certains
certaines convaincre on parle de 30 à 40
milles à certaines pratiques comme
celles on est vraiment dans les bons
chiffres ou pense qu'il ya certaines
pratiques comme celle des faux billets
dont vous parlez qui était à mon avis
anticipable et donc je les dis et je
vais essayer d est ce que c'est pas
l'inversé ce que sap a été surévaluée
dans ce cas sinon je crois qu'il ya eu
une carte vraiment rentable car il ya eu
une carence il ya une carence dans le
renseignement qui a aussi expliqué la
situation qu'on a connus ce soir là
adria 86 on va évoquer le pouvoir
d'achat sa principale préoccupation des
français oui on joue pour le
gouvernement avec un projet de loi en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat des français
qui sera présenté en conseil des
ministres 29 juin prochain avec un
examen dans la foulée au parlement
plusieurs mesures qui notamment vont
être prolongées bouclier tarifaire sur
le gaz électricité triplement de la
prime macron cheikh alimentation des
hausses de certains minima est ce que si
jamais le gouvernement reste en place
les députés de la nuque voteront ce plan
je ne crois pas nous allons faire
d'autres propositions mais comme les
députés ne voterai pas bah écoutez ce
que je vois en tout cas notre logique
n'est pas la même disons les choses
d'abord vous n'avez pas dit qu'il y à
des augmentations de loyer de 10 % qui
sont prévues vous l'avez pas dit non
plus que on prévoit aussi d augmentation
de la facture énergétique avec un
certain nombre de rattrapage mais
pourquoi la logique est elle différente
le gouvernement n'a pas l'intention de
prendre le problème à la racine
l'augmentation des prix que nous avons
aujourd'hui elle est le fait de
spéculations et des faits de marche et
rien d'autre par exemple sur le blé on
est en train de consommer les stocks de
l'année dernière ça n'a donc strictement
à rien à voir avec la guerre en ukraine
ce sont des effets spéculatifs donc le
gouvernement lui ne s'attaque pas du
tout à cela ce qu'il veut faire c'est
par exemple vous distribuer des chèques
qui d'ailleurs dont les montants sont
toujours insuffisants parce que les
français sont pris à la gorge des
chèques ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
prendre de l'argent du trésor public
l'argent des contribuables pour en
quelque sorte garantir la rente privé ça
n'est pas supportable nous ce que nous
voulons faire avec les candidats de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale et avec jean luc mélenchon si
les premiers ministres et si nos
gouvernants c'est ce que nous disons
depuis des mois un blocage des prix à la
baisse sur le même modèle d'ailleurs que
cela est fait dans nos outre-mer je
pense à la réunion où le prix fait à
pouvoir de garantir de contrôle et 153
prix est d'ailleurs on définit lesquels
dans des conseils citoyens voilà il ya
une situation d'urgence sociale et on ne
peut pas supporter que quand d'un côté
les français sont pris à la gorge qu'on
a le carburant à la pompe à plus de 2
euros que le cours du blé est à 450
euros sur les marchés alors que ces 150
d'habitude que le prix des pâtes par
exemple a augmenté de 44 % en un an on
ne peut pas supporter que le
gouvernement ne prennent pas des mesures
à la hauteur alors que dans le même
temps dans le même temps on apprend quoi
que les dividendes des actionnaires du
cac 40 vont augmenter à 2 84 % par
rapport aux chiffres de l'an dernier ça
n'est pas supportable donc oui à des
mesures d'exception immédiates à prendre
et notamment blocage des prix à côté de
quoi ya la question de l'augmentation
des salaires et tout le reste la
politique des petits chèques prix sur le
trésor public pour garantir les rentes
secteur privé ce n'est pas acceptable
dépôt de chèques qu'ils font quand même
entre 15 et 20 milliards d'euros pour le
pouvoir d'achat des français donc ça
vous dit vous ne voterez pas ce n'est
elle ce n'est pas à l'état de garantir
les rentes privé voilà à me donner il
faut mettre fin au mécanisme spéculatif
et dire ce n'est plus possible voilà et
ça c'est un gouvernement peut le faire
vous avez dit qu'il y aurait un
rattrapage sur le sur les sur les prix
notamment au niveau de l'énergie le
bouclier tarifaire bruno le maire à adil
inverse que semble-t-il qui aurait qu
aurait pas de rattrapage sur la facture
des français en 2023 mais il croyait pas
écouté non je n'y crois pas parce que on
reste dans le cadre d'un mécanisme de
marché qui pose de graves problèmes sur
la situation de l'énergie par exemple
que s'est il passé vous voyez bien que
petit à petit on remet en cause toujours
les tarifs réglementés et on passe à une
dérégulation sous l'impulsion de la
commission européenne qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple quand le prix du gaz augmente
alors le prix d'électricité augmente
simplement par effet d'indexation sans
qu aucune réalité matérielle derrière
n'explique cette augmentation de prix
donc si vous voulez dans tous les sujets
que nous abordons à cet instant qu'il
s'agisse du carburant de l'énergie ou
des produits alimentaires des produits
de première nécessité pour l'essentiel
ce sont des effets de marché c'est donc
bien ses effets de marché qu'il faut
casser pour contrôler les prix est ce
que est ce que renationaliser edf serait
une serait une solution mais bien sûr
mais pas faire ce que propose bruno le
maire parce que la mer lancé le maire
l'opposition en quelque sorte qu'il
propose de faire c'est une resucée du
projet hercules qui va consister à 100 d
edf a nationalisé la partie la plus
coûteuse notamment l'entretien de nos
centrales nucléaires mais à privatiser
tout ce qui va rapporter beaucoup
notamment les énergies renouvelables les
réseaux et tout le reste non ce qu'il
conviendrait de faire sur la situation
de l'énergie c'est un grand pôle public
de l'énergie et de sortir de cette
vision absurde et idéologique de la
concurrence libre et non faussée voulue
par la commission européenne veut dire
il ya des domaines dans lesquels on peut
imaginer qu'ils aient de la concurrence
sans que ça pose problème mais là on
l'espèce tout de même la france avait un
opérateur énergétique où on maîtrisait
tout d'un bout à l'autre où ça
fonctionne et est depuis que la
commission européenne avec les
gouvernements successifs complice a
souhaité l'ouverture à la concurrence
c'est le chaos c'est le chaos complet et
moi je ne veux pas qu'on se retrouve
dans des situations que connaissent
certains pays européens on est allé au
bout de la dérégulation où vous avez des
consommateurs des usagers particuliers
qui ont les yeux rivés sur les cours de
bourse pour savoir ce que va donner
leurs factures d'énergie ce n'est pas le
modèle que l'on souhaite pour la france
avec quatre ans une question sur la
réforme des retraites avec d'un côté le
gouvernement et qui prévoit une réforme
de recul de l'âge de départ au moins
jusqu'à 64 ans et de l'autre jean luc
mélenchon et la nuque qui souhaitent une
réforme de la retraite à 60 ans avec 40
années de cotisation et selon le journal
les échos à bien cette réforme des
retraites de jean-luc mélenchon elle
pourrait coûter près de 100 milliards
d'euros est ce que vous confirmez ce
chiffre est et ce qu'elle est totalement
financé votre erreur d'abord ses 71
milliards d'euros la réforme elle prend
et à la plusieurs piliers de la réforme
il ya le droit de partir à 60 ans le
rétablissement du droit à la retraite à
60 ans il ya le fait de garantir
qu'aucune pensions de retraite quel
qu'ait été votre carrière ne se trouve
sous le seuil de pauvreté c'est 1000 63
euros aujourd'hui j'insiste bien qu elle
qui a été votre carrière parce que
emmanuel macron lui vous offre ça pour
une carrière complète et avec 65 ans
comme âge de départ à terme et de
l'autre côté c'est que pour une carrière
complète dans notre réforme aucune
retraite ne serait inférieur au smic
dont vous savez que nous voulons de
revaloriser à 1500 euros là pour 72
milliards moi je veux mettre à l'aise
tout le monde et expliquer pourquoi ce
raisonnement est valable pourquoi c'est
juste de le faire un travailleur
français aujourd'hui en 2022 produit à
lui seul trois fois plus de richesses
qu'un travailleur français d'il ya 50
ans parce qu'il ya eu des gains de
productivité des bonds technologiques et
tout le reste est ce que vous avez vu
que les salaires ont augmenté de la même
proportion ou le temps de travail a
diminué de la même proportion non donc
où vont les gains de productivité quand
vous voyez par exemple que ces dix
dernières années les dividendes versés
aux actionnaires ont progressé de 70%
mais que les salaires eux n'ont
progressé que de 10 12% vous comprenez
qu'en réalité la question du financement
des retraites ce n'est qu'une question
de partage de la richesse donc moi je le
dis très clairement vous avez une ample
majorité je crois que c'est 71% des
français pendant derniers sondages qui
souhaitent le rétablissement de la
retraite à 60 ans ils ont raison et ils
doivent savoir que si les 12 et 19 juin
ils votent pour des candidates et
candidats de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale et que nous sommes
en majorité nous gouvernerons et cette
réforme de la retraite à 60 ans je
m'engage personnellement à ce qu'elles
soient réalisées au plus vite on va
finir cette interview par la campagne
des élections législatives avec en
sondages sondage doxa mascaret pour les
chaînes parlementaires et la presse
régionale qui estime qu'il y aura et
bien 53 % d'abstention au premier tour
des législatives le 12 juin prochain
avec une abstention qui est encore plus
forte chez les plus jeunes plus de 60%
également chez les employés et les
ouvriers 59 % justement les jeunes les
employés les ouvriers il compose une
partie importante de votre électorat est
ce que vous ne craignez pas que vos
électeurs soit démobilisés pour ces
législatives écoutez j'observe que
depuis que nous avons fixés l'enjeu
c'est à dire rappelé que l'élection
législative n'a pas vocation à donner
une majorité au président de la
république si c'était la vocation
l'élection pourrait l'annuler d'ailleurs
ce qu'on leur donne une majorité au
président élu on n'en parle plus là on
est en train de redonner du sens à ces
élections législatives de dire elles
vont fixer le cap politique des cinq
prochaines années et c'est pas parce que
monsieur macron à gagner l'élection
présidentielle
à la faveur de son duel avec l'extrême
droite que vous n'avez plus droit à ce
programme que beaucoup d'entre vous ont
souhaité donc les 12 et 19 juin c'est
une élection extrêmement importante
c'est une élection pour la conquête du
pouvoir disons le quand l'entente madame
le pen dire non non c'est normal que
monsieur macron et sa majorité je dire
c'est insupportable en réalité c'est une
élection pour la conquête du pouvoir
donc avec la constitution de cette
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale c'est à dire un rassemblement
très large sur un programme de rupture
nous créons les conditions pour toutes
celles et ceux qui veulent que ça change
véritablement qu'on bloque les prix
qu'on augmente le smic qu'on fasse la
retraite à 60 ans la planification
écologique ne leur disons si vous votez
c'est possible et toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion montrent que c'est à portée de
main à la condition bien sûr qu'il y ait
la mobilisation donc nous nous avons
fait notre part du travail nous sommes
en campagne jeudi aux électrices et aux
électeurs à vous de faire la vôtre et
mesurer la portée historique de ce que
nous sommes en train de faire si vous le
décidez individuellement et vous avez
les responsabilités individuelles le
jour du vote les 12 et 19 vous pouvez
bâtir cette majorité vous pouvez envoyer
jean luc mélenchon à matignon est
derrière jean-luc mélenchon à matignon
vous avez compris ce n'est pas l'enjeu
de sa personne c'est l'enjeu d'un
programme qu'on peut encore appliquée
parce que dans la constitution le
premier ministre détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation voilà l'enjeu de
l'élection législative alors françois
hollande l'ancien président la
république dans cette campagne des
législatives et bien il a il était sur
le terrain en corrèze pour soutenir une
dissidente socialiste annick tess
dissidente face à la candidate face au
candidat de la nuque vous êtes surpris
par cette campagne de françois hollande
compte contre les l'union des gauches
surpris non mais je crois que ce que
fait françois hollande l'un des plus
grands need intérêts ni ni forte
audience ouailles et je pense que ça n'a
pas une grande portée non j'insiste bien
sur le fait que la constitution cette
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale ravivent l'espoir dans
énormément d'endroits et que je suis
assez surpris positivement de voir que
partout on se déplace même si j'entends
qu'il ya un enjeu de mobilisation il
faut le rappeler vous avérée mais
globalement moi qui ai connu la campagne
des législatives précédentes celle de
2017 je peux vous dire qu'à l'époque on
n'entendait pas des gens nous
interpellait à propos du mois de juin en
parlant d'un troisième tour de la
présidentielle là disons que les mots
d'ordre et les dates déjà sont assez
connus donc il ya une mobilisation qui
me paraît plus forte maintenant c'est
clair que vous l'avez dit dans certains
secteurs notamment les employés les
ouvriers et les jeunes qui votent
massivement notamment pour jean luc
mélenchon et pour la nouvelle union
populaire je le redis mobilisez-vous
parce que peut-être vous ne mesurez pas
que ces élections législatives sont
peut-être encore plus importante même vu
la configuration politique que
l'élection présidentielle et que tout
cela est possible dans quelques jours si
nous sommes majoritaires le 19 juin au
soir c'est dans les jours suivants que
jean luc mélenchon est nommé premier
ministre et qu'on forme un gouvernement
tout va bien aussi à la nouvelle
alliance fallait nouvelle union
populaire veut parlez nous un peu de
fabien roussel qu'on voit pas beaucoup
finalement voté pour parler de fabien
roussel et gruner pour parler de fabien
roussel vous me permettrez de vous
suggérer de lui téléphoner et d'inviter
sur ce plateau fabien roussel leader les
choses très franchement sur l'envergure
de l'alliance historique que nous sommes
en train de faire don j'insiste bien sur
le fait qu'elle n'est pas un simple
accord électoral
si nous avions voulu faire simplement un
accord électoral c'eût été plus facile
ce que nous avons fait là c'est un
accord programmatique je rappelle qu'on
a un programme partagé de gouvernement
que tout le monde peut aller retrouver
de 650 mesure 8 chapitres et que nous
nous sommes accordés sur l'ensemble des
circonscriptions du territoire donc
c'est historique donc si vous voulez sur
un accord aussi massif 30 et
éventuellement quelques difficultés
c'est extrêmement minoritaire fabien
roussel était minoritaire mais c'est
fabien roussel est fabien roussel lundi
date fabien roussel et techniciens
présents lors de la la la première le
premier événement que nous avons tenu un
bon la part aux fondations va écouter il
a peut-être de bonnes excuses il a aussi
une campagne à mener enfin voilà
interrogé le lui vous n'allez pas être
en mesure de me faire dire telle ou
telle chose je veux dire il ya un
candidat dans sa circonscription de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale c'est fabien roussel et ya pas
de discussion là dessus mais on finira
sur ces mots merci beaucoup avec quatre
ans d'avancé vous on était invités
politiques aujourd'hui
[Musique]